look at these puppies
i know you can't see them i know you can
see this all right nice t-shirts right
gina has big boobs and she's trying to
sell a shirt on top of it
our shirts say no matter what phase
you're in you're always whole
even if you have small boobies you're a
whole too you're still home yeah yeah
and right now we're having a lot yeah
you're not a lot yeah thank you
thank you for that nikki we have these
lovely shirts that we've worked on we
would love for you to buy some of our
merch uh this is a limited stock run
we're not doing this again so if you
want to get some of the sizes are
already running out so sorry about that
but um you know go check and see what
we've got left and uh grab one we're
having a sale it's perfect for halloween
look at
yes 20 off if you want to get one it's
your last chance so hurry up and grab
one at bigmoodstore.com
[Music]
welcome back to big mood hello everyone
today we have a very beautiful guest
named stacy diaz and
a whatever
guest just kidding
whatever host that you need to give her
already
yeah who else is here who's the whatever
person mickey
[Applause]
yeah so
and me yeah i'm not whatever i'm the
host and
and the baby
the baby
the little tiny guest host
give it a little baby mic yeah
as it gets bigger you could the
heartbeat just gets in the podcast i
bought i bought a doppler recently they
call it like a fetal doppler so if you
feel the heartbeat i haven't used it yet
but i'm excited to use it anyway i saw a
comment on you guys this video that i
died laughing or was it our video it
said
because my boob job and your pregnancy
they're like wow gina's less 100 human
and tiff is now 100 more human
[Music]
that was awesome but anyway so today
we're gonna be answering your
submissions because you guys submitted a
should you break up uh submission or
should you go back to the streets yes to
the street back to the streets or stay
in your relationship try to work it out
stay with your person yeah and uh we're
excited to have stacy here because yeah
extra input this is my bread and butter
you guys i love it all my content i
always get questions like this by
different women my dms are open it's not
guaranteed that i will answer because a
lot of times it's you know a lot of
people but anyway um you're so popular
hello
i'm like you know obama i'm more popular
than him okay
no but for real i do get a lot of the
requests are those yeah you post on your
stories like i like your they're
thought-provoking where it's like do you
think that this is okay and it's like
how do i
pass well you always pass regardless of
what you choose but my tick tock is all
like relationship questions like this
this is like
rapid fire let's go yeah
so bad but it's in spanish
that's awesome i love it sorry everybody
all right so our first submission
uh would you like to name these people
stacy or should gina continue to take
over because she names these people well
you name them yeah
you go ahead you're really good at that
dr phil okay before or after you hear
this uh before before we'll name this
one aguas
all right so they write i truly don't
know what to do i found out november
2019 that my boyfriend of almost one
year had been cheating on me when i
found out he owned up to it told his
parents his older respected brother and
completely changed he started caring
about my mental health talked to me
about depression he doesn't allow us to
fight he calms me down and talks it out
with me he's never put the blame on me
or made me feel that something was my
fault he's legit become a great man but
i cannot let go of what he did or i
guess how he hid it so well
but i wasn't perfect either i was i was
telling my ex-boyfriend of six years
that i still loved him i would text him
and talk to him every chance i could a
part of me wants to stay and enjoy the
man
my now fiance is he proposed this month
but the other part of me just wants to
let it go he has a seven-year-old
daughter and i don't even think i want
kids so that's another thing i love him
and we run our businesses side by side
with each other he's a contractor and
i'm a realtor we laugh at everything and
legit finish each other's sentences we
have this thing called mental text
messages because he'll legit say what
i'm thinking and vice versa i just want
to let it go his mistake my mistake
every time i vent to him i tell him i
wish he would have gone through this
with somebody else and then met me he's
a great man he's a great man now i just
don't know if i'm going to be the one to
enjoy him or if i'm even meant to be
like
my
reaction is it broke for you a long time
ago like and it's it sucks because
logistically you want to be like like
logically you're like oh on paper like
he's like the perfect guy now and like
he changed for me and he's he's there he
supports me like why wouldn't i like
this man but in your heart it's like you
feel something's off something's wrong
it wasn't hiding it for months yeah like
because
that's the
the thing happened so long ago but the
fact that you had to find out now
whichever way she found out you've been
living a lie this whole time yeah and
that's what sucks because what was real
and what wasn't it exactly yeah so and
also i just feel like okay so like let's
say you like this piece of paper and
this is your relationship it's like okay
then the paper gets crinkled yeah and
you find and you find this crinkled
people's paper and he's like oh no no
let me fix it i'll iron it back out look
it it's the same paper it was before but
now it's not you could never get rid of
those wrinkles yeah ankles are always
going to be there and they
changed the base of your relationship
yeah there was no base to begin with
because it was a lie yeah i think also a
big part is he has a child and you're
straight up just like i don't even want
kids that's yeah you can't accept that i
don't think this is ever going to work
maybe even the cheating part might even
be like an excuse for you for the child
because i don't know that that to me is
even way
bigger more important more serious to
consider because that's not something
you can just work out ever yeah the
kid's gonna be there yeah yeah and you
have to accept your partner
holy like this the kid is still a part
of him it's still
it's what you're marrying into this kid
is gonna be your family too so yeah if
you can't accept the whole package
then i don't know i don't personally
think that
it's the right fit i don't think so
either i think she's over romanticizing
him whoever it is that who sent this
i think
i was yeah i think there's a little bit
of a over romanticizing of this man
because it's not like
healthy men cheat right so if he was
cheating he's probably not that great to
begin with
and if you're so super into him that
you're like he's the best he's totally
changed around then you wouldn't really
feel like texting your ex of six years
and telling him that you still love him
like those feelings just wouldn't come
out to like if you really
cared about it to me it sounded the
texting her ex part was at the same time
he was cheating but i could have
misinterpreted it right but either way
in the relationship already yeah if
you're in a relationship there's no
reason to be texting your ex yeah so if
both people were problematic it doesn't
matter if one or both were problematic
there's a reason like you guys were
doing those things
and if you really like genuinely like
this was
like meant to be this was for you and
this was you like you love this person
so much like i just don't think you
would even be tempted to do those things
yeah it seems like you have some
unfinished business with your ex too
yeah or with yourself in therapy yeah i
don't know my opinions on this are a
little conflicted because i kind of
relate like oh what would you do tiff um
well i mean what what have i already
done because like i mean obviously not
the exact same situation
not the same situation like casey didn't
cheat on me or anything
but like we did have a lot of issues
that led to trust issues that i felt our
relationship was that crinkled up paper
and
you know like and then now like through
therapy and like so much growth so much
healing so much
understanding like we've gotten to a
really good place where i feel like the
paper is like practically ironed out
there's still some crinkles in there
that's like i don't know if they will
ever come out i hope they do because it
would only make our relationship better
and we're working towards clearing out
those crinkles and we're
you know we're that's the goal and we're
in it together to fix it yes and so
that's the thing that like i don't i
don't really know what my opinion about
this particular situation is because in
her eyes she's not viewing her
relationship the same way i was when i
was in a really bad place because when i
was
i
when i was in like the worst place in
our relationship i never wanted to let
it go like i saw it as like [ __ ] i think
i'm gonna have to because this is just
so like it's gotten so ugly like i don't
even know if it's repairable but i want
to repair it and i want to get over it
and i see a good future if we can just
get through this together and
from her the way she's speaking it just
sounds like
it's not even possible for her to like
well the difference here is that you
you're married and she's not that's a
good point i mean you engage but yeah
yeah it's not the same and
the and the other huge difference no one
else was brought into this marriage
right
you know like you guys are like no other
person was ever brought in yeah because
i think when
you bring a third person into the
relationship that's when everything
starts to fall apart because it's no
longer just two people every
relationship has problems all of them
you know and some get a lot more dark
than others but
i think the minute you bring somebody
else is it's no longer two people and
here the relationship they were just
boyfriend and girlfriend he's already
bringing somebody else when it gets to
real stuff in a marriage like you guys
imagine what's he gonna do run to
somebody else yeah that's his cup yeah
and i don't like how she's one of her
reasons for staying is like oh we run
our businesses side by side yeah okay
then you start adding more things on and
she's like trying it harder to logically
break up like let's say it gets really
toxic let's say he cheats again and it's
like this time he doesn't change his
behavior it's like he's just wants to
cheat on you and now you're married so
there's legal separation like all these
proceedings for divorce you also have
the businesses and whatever else you
introduce maybe you have kids maybe
sometimes
you know you think something's gonna
work out and you make these big life
decisions because you think it'll fix it
like and
it doesn't fix it it just makes it
harder to leave each other i think what
you're seeing what she's seeing is that
this is this might not
be you're meant to be this is probably
like maybe you guys are meant to be like
really good friends yeah and you just
gotta love each other yeah it's just
gonna be a lesson yeah
i think when it's boyfriend and
girlfriend it should be as like
pink and beautiful as possible because
if you're already seeing problems in
this stage by the time that the marriage
hits
it's gonna get worse right so
this is when you break up over the
smallest things when your boyfriend and
girlfriend it's like he looked at
someone the wrong way bye
because this is the time this is your
trial for a serious relationship when
you're married that's it it's your
interview process yeah kind of like a
relationship is like an interview
process where he cheated on me by at the
first time she was messaging other girls
bye
he why why are you staying he's only
your boyfriend it comes down to what
your
boundaries are like personal because for
me cheat you're out by gone
however the first year of steve and i
being together we fought all the time
and like there was a reason we stayed
together which was that each time we
fought we were really good at
communicating and finding the solution
together and then we would grow stronger
each time so the next time we fought it
would never be about the same thing it
was always like a new thing that we had
to learn about each other and then grow
from and so that to me
even though that was the hardest year
where it should have been like usually
the first year people are together it's
like the roses like the pink and blue
right yeah but no for us it was like the
darkest because we were projecting a lot
from other relationships but also so
understanding of each other and able to
figure out a communication system that
made our relationship super super strong
so after that first year it was like
nothing could break through yeah that
only
happened like that can only work when
both parties are willing to work on it
and like not until
both parties are and it wasn't too
broken he didn't cheat on me if so you
cheated on me
bye yeah
there's some non-negotiables yeah you
have to have a few non-negotiables i
don't know what yours are some people
are okay with cheating they can get back
together after for me i can never trust
you again so
like that's just
yeah i said this girl you should break
up with him
all right we're ready for the next one
you're ready okay
uh
all
right
this one's a guy okay rhino tooth right
right it's rhino2nal toes
they were like you gotta develop thick
skin like a rhinoceros or whatever
his name is
sorry okay my name is rhinosaurus
rhinoceros thank you yeah
that was like
rhinosaur
it was a really deep sales class
that's hilarious okay what is it right
no
flames rhino toes rhino toes okay rhino
toes right get those looked at
hello big mood girls hi i found her i
found your channel randomly and really
enjoy all of your personalities oh
that's cool i like to remain anonymous
okay okay rhino toads i'm a guy and this
is my story with my girlfriend me and my
girlfriend met in our senior year of
high school and began dating then
we are the same age when i asked her out
she was really nice and fun we went on a
couple of private dates until she
decided to introduce me to her family
everything went south from there her
parents immediately told her i am not a
good guy and that i just want to use
women i was very hurtful because at
times they would get into her head and
have her insecure or not trust me i kept
pushing and being supportive and proving
my intentions to her and she never felt
that way again unfortunately then it got
worse as we grew in our relationship at
this point we were one year and a half
and we had sex multiple times once her
family discovered that she was still
seeing me they banned her from seeing me
again they took her everywhere she
needed to go they never let her leave
her leave the house with her friends and
she only communicated with me through
facetime in the night time
i found this behavior kind of odd since
we were both 19 years old and i never
seen someone be treated that way that's
when she explained that her family is
very religious
and that's why they are treating her
like this we're still pushing harder and
harder every day but i still can't see
her
only by sneaking out and that is very
stressful to the point i don't want to
hang out this way anymore we've been
doing the sneaking relationship for the
past two years and now we're both 21.
this is my problem the family is pushing
me away because they think our
relationship won't last but at the same
time i don't feel too happy behaving
this way i don't know how to feel if i
should break up with the person and
leave them in this situation or if we
should keep fighting until we see each
other again what should we do marry her
she wants to see her
and he wants i mean here it sounds like
you guys started really young right
but i personally think if you're serious
about this girl and she obviously has a
religious family and
what do her parents want if you guys had
kids and you were really strict i mean
i'm going to be really strict what do
you want a good man that's going to take
care of your daughter if you're that for
her step up to the plate if you're not
then let her go they're not going to
approve that marriage ever she has to
run off and do it herself and then just
possibly deal with not seeing her family
again they cut her off like crazy
religion yeah it depends it does sound
like he's a bad guy yeah well i think
that's what i'm like i'm confused
because i feel like there's a lot of
holes here i think so too why don't they
like him yeah like i need to know like
what their reasoning is even if it's
wrong i just want to know like what is
making them think
that you're a bad guy like right off the
bat like from a dinner is it because
you're a different religion is it
because
they didn't like the way you said
something like i kind of just want to
know that missing piece of information
just because that might be able to help
you have a better relationship with the
family because without without knowing
what they don't like about you you can
never resolve that
and
um when it comes to the religion thing
i'm also confused at like what exactly
is it is it because you're a different
religion or is it because you're the
same religion but you aren't operating
as orthodox as they would like you to
like what traditions are you breaking
like what do you what's what's the
problem i want to know and also like do
they do this with every guy she's ever
had in her life or is this unique to him
i want to know that too i think that's
why i said like if if you want something
serious with her like just go all the
way right because a lot of times really
religious people will
marry really young so that they can have
the freedom to be in a relationship so
if let's say they're both christian
that's probably what would happen a lot
of people get married really young
because of that so i think he's
you might not be telling us everything
yeah i think that's part of it and then
i also think like
i wouldn't marry just to
just for that reason right yeah you know
that's then you're stuck in this thing
like oh so you're 20 yeah they're too
young
and there's so much you haven't learned
about yourself and there's so much you
probably haven't learned about her
especially if you're not even allowed to
like see each other very often like
she's basically like like if you count
on the amount of times you spent
together it's
a month
yeah yeah it doesn't feel like that one
year that year i know right you're like
i'm in love yeah i love that's what i'm
like don't rush into marriage
getting more and more infatuated with
her because he maybe because he he knows
it's being denied yeah yeah so it's like
when you can't have something you want
it more yep and then also i was thinking
too um
what was your first point just now um
the the missing details uh like oh my
brain pregnancy right what part of
religion it went blank yeah i had a
comment on some the first thing you said
well he sounds like he has a problem and
he needs someone to talk to and if you
want to talk to someone we have talk
space
as the year ends another holiday season
is upon us and for many of us that means
travel and family
and for many of us also family brings
some stress
that
that can possibly come up uh so tis the
seasons to be jolly but sometimes it
just doesn't feel that way and that's
okay e some of the burdens the holidays
can bring with talkspace online therapy
talkspace is the number one online
therapy platform i've actually tried
talkspace before it's a
app that you can go on and talk to a
real therapist any time you want and i
loved it because i can always just dump
my feelings out all at once instead of
waiting for one
appointment a week um i can just message
my therapist whenever i want whether it
be text voice video and they check their
phones and they message you back
uh five days a week and it feels like
it's just always so nice to have someone
to talk to yeah especially around the
holidays exactly sometimes you just feel
like oh my goodness this is a lot
i need to talk to someone exactly
uh talkspace is the number one online
therapy platform there are thousands of
licensed therapists available for you to
match with across dozens of specialties
including anxiety depression
relationships and more talkspace is
ready to help you start feeling better
with a single message talkspace works
around your schedule at your convenience
with live video sessions and unlimited
messages with your dedicated therapist
you can also set goals with your
therapist and develop techniques to cope
in difficult times like the holidays
talkspace offers individual therapy
couples therapy and medication
prescription services so if you need a
little support to help you through the
end of the year or want to start
building towards a better upcoming year
talkspace is here to help match with a
licensed therapist when you go to
talkspace.com and get a hundred dollars
off your first month with the promo code
mood that's a hundred dollars off when
you use the code mood talkspace.com
that's a lot of doll hairs that's a lot
of doll hairs and usually after i talk
to my therapist i have to go poop
yeah you got to let it all out yeah let
it all out let all that toxic waste down
exactly both ends and when you poop you
should clean your butt butt real clean
with water and that's where hello tishi
comes in hello tishi is the modern bidet
for people who poop just poop wash and
pat dry it washes your butt with water
for a better clean than toilet paper and
water is less irritating and more
soothing for your butthole it's also
very easy to install it attaches to a
toilet in under 10 minutes and you don't
need electricity or plumbing using a
hello tissue also reduces your toilet
paper use by 80 percent saving you money
it's also eco-friendly and very stylish
hello tishi also has a full product line
to help your restroom sexy so wet so
sexy
they have the hello tishi ottoman the
sleekest toilet stool designed to help
you poop at 100 100 of the time it is
rated number one by the wire cutter they
also have a hella tushy brush and it's
the only toilet brush with disposable
scrubbing pad so you can use a clean
brush every time so start washing with a
hello tissue bidet for a better clean go
to helloteacher.com big mood to get 10
off plus free shipping this is a special
offer for all of our listeners at
hellotissue.com
big mood for 10 off after you buy and
install your yellow tissue show it off
tag us and at hello tishi on instagram
so we can see it not your body yeah it's
not your butt butt i don't want to see
that show me your butt but i mean
but don't do that
hello to you okay i think i remember
what i wanted to say but i don't know if
it was
based off of what you said just say it
but the other comment that i had when i
was reading this
um from rhino toes
he also said that he didn't he said i
don't know how to feel if i should break
up with the person and leave them in
this situation it sounds like he's
he's like trying to rescue her from this
too but he can't do anything about it if
it's her family and the fact that
they're latching on so hard to her where
she can't even leave her house without
them like
i'm like that's her situation to deal
with like the fact that like i really
think that he's just infatuated because
he can't have her another red flag for
me is that he didn't list any reasons
why he loves this person or likes this
person like it just seems like a i dated
her she was fun and now i'm being
restricted and then and that's so we
just kept dating and i don't know why
you like this person is it a connection
worth fighting for what is specifically
about this person is something that you
can't live without because well i think
like he doesn't need to go into detail
very much
he doesn't but it's the fact that he's
asking that lets us know
that he doesn't see the full worth
because there's plenty of girls with
strict parents who have boyfriends yeah
and the boyfriends come over and stay
there from nine in the morning till 12
p.m and they go home and they can't see
them until next sunday from nine in the
morning
and some guys are okay with that like
they're like i love her so this is what
it is until we get married or her
parents like me especially when you're
so young i'm trying to say it on his end
too because i know of like really really
strict asian parents too all the way
into like um
like uh shawn's girlfriend her parents
were extremely strict
and one day she's like or their parents
were like or her parents were like okay
yeah you guys are moving together how
long were they together
uh
i don't know i mean they've been
together for years but from what i knew
she was like really strict she wasn't
all to get a job or anything so it was
it was very interesting assuming it was
also another um another example
of someone that was dating
this girl and she had super strict
parents and
they were dating for years but
unfortunately it was
in secrecy because her parents would
never accept him because he was of a
different religion i think it was i
think i'm talking about that yeah it was
just like something
fundamentally different that her parents
would never accept him for and
i think at that point when the parents
are have such a huge say in the love
life of their child like
it's up to that that child like the you
know the person in the relationship if
i'm gonna
if i'm gonna honor my parents i no
longer can can be in this relationship
let me stop wasting your time because
i'm gonna do what they want or on the
other end it's like hey like i i love
you i choose you like we'll figure it
out with my parents but i'm i'm picking
you and it seems like this girl you know
she's already 21 and she's not
able to do that
for him so clearly it's not
it's just not gonna work so do you guys
think he should stay or leave i think
you should go back to the streets back
to the street i personally think he
should
marry stay and
try to see if she's open to
pretty much just telling her parents
like look man i'm 21 years old like yeah
i i can i can do this i'm an adult i can
go get my own job if this doesn't work
out or if
like she's 21 years old she can go get a
job if she wants to and she can move out
if she wants to also she probably
doesn't yeah you know yeah if it hasn't
happened yet yeah that's what i'm saying
well i don't know because like i said um
like sean's ex or sean's girlfriend you
know they were very strict and they
still are together till this day and the
parents finally let up and they're
living together now do the parents say
we'd all like this guy yeah that he's a
bad person that's important
and then comes my other friend same
thing her parents did not like him at
all but then eventually she put her foot
down she's like look this is who makes
me happy see that's what has to happen
exactly so maybe he doesn't have to
break up with her maybe this is at the
time where they really have to have this
talk and be like look i agree you need
to set up to your parents because you're
an adult now yeah and
i'm not making you choose between what
is it choosing between it's not just
standing up for yourself it is but at
that point if i'm the parent i'm gonna
say
when you pay your own bills and you
don't live under my house you can do
whatever you want and you're not leaving
my house until you get married so you
know what i mean like so i know
it's probably unpopular but when you
care about your child like that i feel
like
you want the best for them the yeah i i
was with you up until the you're not
leaving me hot my house until you're
married oh yeah that one i'm like that's
different for everybody yeah we i don't
agree with it but
i think she's saying like if the parents
are that restrictive no their parents
are being toxic yeah yeah
they're already that's established like
they're very controlling they want
complete control over their daughter's
love life
um honestly like sometimes it's like
this in indian cultures i've had indian
friends where they like the parents only
want them to marry an indian person so
like the it's arranged marriages in that
culture so there's it just operates
differently it might be that i don't
know but um
but if it's like you know
if your cultures just aren't lining up
and
the person doesn't want to fight and
stand up and be like no this is my man
and i don't care what you say and then
yeah i would just let it go you're
really young if you're meant to be maybe
you'll find your way back to each other
true later but it sounds like the
timing's not right it's meant to work
out so maybe not back in the streets but
have a serious talk put one foot in the
street one foot in the streets yeah
one rhino toe on the street one right
now a single rhino two in the streets
next one this is a girl gina
nikki's breasts nikki's breasts yeah
you're there yeah
which one right or left nick both
breasts
breasts for us
[Laughter]
so she says
so we have been together for probably
going on three years now we have lived
together for about a year i somehow
always find shady things he is saying to
females that still live in his hometown
that he has known for years
i recently saw messages between him and
a co-worker with him saying i miss your
lips
ladies and gentlemen to the streets
he says run he says i miss your lips and
i crave your naked body
yeah um
i saw this and left with my daughter
because i needed space good for you i
don't know if they share this daughter
or if it's her daughter i don't know uh
when i first approached him about it he
was not apologetic
i don't know what she's going to say
that's going to save this because you
know this sounds real bad i'm not to
come over and pack your bags for you
three days went by three days went by
and i went back home he was very
apologetic and begged me not to leave
him he says he just does these kinds of
things for attention because he's never
been the type of guy that can ever get
the girl he's lying
he has the girl he's lying
he's lying
but go ahead girl just stab him yeah
honestly
he's a great person nope no he's not
he's messaging other women he's a
manipulative person and he has convinced
you that he's a great person yeah he's
not a great man anyway but right now i
feel like i don't know him you don't
swears he never cheated physically he
only cheated emotionally narcissist yes
which somehow makes me feel worse
because he's still cheating i gave him
the choice to be free and go find his
happiness but he refused he says he
wants to marry me and i am his forever
no because you're rejecting him right
now he only fights for things that he is
being rejected by mm-hmm as soon as you
accept him back he's back to another
girl for him yeah he's just saying
whatever you want to hear yeah so you
don't leave he can't be the one that's
being broken up with because he is a
narcissist oh yeah
he loves what we have but he somehow
can't fight the need for wanting to be
wanting the attention from other females
nope i don't know what to do anymore
because he is the love of my life
he recently started trying to get closer
to god and i do see some changes in him
but will this time finally be the time
he changes god this reminds me of my ex
so bad this reminds me of the recent one
that i outed also because now and they
have the same name
oh yeah because he's like all religious
now like i found god yeah yeah so they
they do these outrageous tactics to make
you believe that they change yeah but
this is the same name as your ex yeah oh
i got confused where i was like how do
you know the name of her guy yeah yeah
yeah
wait is that all she said no no okay
continue okay
i can't do this i mean i know it's
making me feel icky yeah
he says he wants us he wants us both to
get closer to god and wants us both to
grow together should i stay and keep my
faith in the hopes that will be a new
that there will be a new leaf for us or
should i give up on the hopes of him
having these positive changes several
emotional ties right now
i am closer to god
i am not sure how we can fix the trust
that has been broken and this isn't the
first time i have seen shady things on
his phone
this is also one of the first times he
has ever been very emotional and very
afraid to use me
also side note he doesn't work with that
girl anymore don't fall from that one so
the the closer you are to leaving the
sweeter and more emotional more
emotional the more speech is that yeah
yeah yeah he's like going to church now
oh my god
where um this girl says my mother knew
what was going on the moment he bought
her flowers for the first time oh yeah i
saw that yeah
like
the guy would never bring her flowers
the mom and then
all of a sudden like he brought a
bouquet of flowers and the mom was like
oh [ __ ] like something's happening
to the mom to the mom
the husband yeah the husband suddenly
bought flowers for the wife the wife for
the first time what happened what did he
do yeah like he feels guilty and she
said that's when i knew he was cheating
at me yeah my ex would buy me gifts too
right after i would find things wow yeah
um
i want you to maybe look into and i'm
not saying this is you but maybe just
look into it and see if it rings true
look up codependency and narcissism
because they attract each other so it
sounds like you might be a little
codependent it sounds like your
boyfriend is a narcissist and
the quicker you can learn about these
two personalities mixing with each other
you can break away from it and you can
break your pattern yeah and also if he's
not a narcissist he's a cheater yeah and
that's really enough yeah and
manipulative that's enough
baby baby no i love you i just can't
help this part of me that needs
attention from other girls because i've
never been the guy that gets the girl
but you're with me
you got the girl yeah like what other
girl you didn't get yeah what didn't you
get that's just victimizing himself like
yeah no
it's not you and it's not me it's my own
it's this disease i have that makes me
need attention from girls yeah and
that's never going to go away
and if you marry him
he knows that as long as he tells you
that story you'll stay and then you're
married
i'm a changed man and you could come
with me you'll see
oh yeah run yeah yeah run the [ __ ] out
back to the streets run into the streets
it's hard because you want to believe
that they're different you want to
believe them because you as a person
would never make these promises and not
mean it yeah and so you want to believe
that everyone else operates the way that
you do but they don't yeah you don't
people like this do not mean what they
say in the same way
yeah it really really sucks sorry he
does mickey's breast the eye
nicky's crusty
[Laughter]
but he's this is not a good situation
you need all of us no physically ill
here yes also
for any of you who have
a partner
that gets caught with something and they
immediately
uh they they don't fess up to it if
anything they deny it or if they get
angry at you for finding out yeah
[ __ ] run yeah because that is an
uphill battle that is not even [ __ ]
worth it it's not worth that like
fighting that ego and fighting that
[ __ ]
it's just or if you get uh a real fun
time is when they are a comedian and
they are like no it was a joke are you
serious and they love the gaslight and
you're like you didn't get that that was
a joke come on like it's just me [ __ ]
around with my friend like
of course i'm not gonna want her nudes
oh my god that's so crazy yeah you're so
crazy aren't you crazy your judgment's
off you have terrible judgment and then
you start thinking that you have
terrible judgment just run yeah and
first of all he didn't even beg you to
come back and you came back yeah
he wasn't apologetic till you were
leaving yeah
yeah girl
damn i feel i feel so bad because that's
hurtful it is hurtful but honestly let
it hurt all of them let it hurt and grow
let it hurt a lot of things hurt run
them over
yeah i mean not yet to that but what
stacy just said run them over in your
mind for entertainment
metaphorically running over
in your mind with your metaphorical
cause okay
okay next one uh female
okay oh okay uh tiffany's uterus
yeah they're hosting a baby right now
okay can we call her the ute the ute
yeah okay the youth says hi i've been
loving your episodes please keep me
anonymous
but i've been dating this guy for four
years and i still don't feel certain
about the relationship i know part of it
is my own anxiety and overthinking
that's holding me back but sometimes
there are things that make me feel like
he's not right for me like for example
one time he got mad that i got a bit too
drunk while we were out with our friends
and his reason was because he had to
take care of me and so he couldn't hang
out with his friends like he had planned
or when i was really upset at work after
being scolded by a senior and he and all
he said was i just don't see why you're
so upset and completely shut me down
even though i was crying he just ignored
me but when we hang out it's still so
much fun and i still love him a lot it's
just that when we are when there are
hard times i feel like he can't be there
for me like i need him to be anyway
sorry for the ramble and thanks in
advance looking forward to the new
episode okay so i have something to say
about this because i've been through
this before let us hear it i couldn't
put my finger on it in my previous
relationship as to
like we have such a great time but when
it came down to like conflicts or
something wrong with me he didn't know
how to comfort me or anything he just
kind of sit there like
what's your problem or like can you not
you know
and then i came it came to realize that
um this person
clearly cares about you like you you
know that you love each other and he
cares about you and all that stuff but
the thing is he cannot take care of you
and that is such a huge part in a
relationship because
what happens when you're like he can
always be like yeah yeah you know like i
love you you're so cool we have so much
fun i care so much about you if you died
i'd be so sad but can he actually take
care of you yeah can he take care of you
if like if you're old and gray and you
can't move anymore is he gonna be there
and be like i don't know why you can't
why you need a diaper you know like you
get sick will he leave you immediately
exactly if you die can he take care of
your kids
so it really comes down to can you be
with someone who
cannot take care of you there's a huge
difference well also i like to add to
that so
when you said he got upset at me because
i got too drunk and he couldn't hang out
with his friends
i would be upset if my boyfriend got too
drunk and i couldn't enjoy the night
because i had to take care of him so for
example could i live the rest of my life
with my boy what my fiance and if he
let's say cancel but if he got sick
would i take care of him absolutely yes
but if we have a plan to go out and
we're both responsible to not have too
many drinks i expect you to hold your
own in that scenario because you then
ruined my night because i had to babysit
you that's no longer so that's a
conversation yeah yeah that's i think
that's okay for him to have that
boundary to say hey don't get too drunk
because i want to have fun too he's not
your dad yeah i think it's in the way
that maybe because i agree with you
maybe he needs to communicate that
better like that that's a boundary for
him yeah and yeah i agree i think the
difference is like on the second one
where you're like venting to him and
he's like invalidating yeah deal with
your own [ __ ] that's probably where like
the red flag starts to pop up but if
everything else in the relationship is
really amazing and everything's
wonderful and things are great and you
get along great i think that could fix
what that could be fixed with therapy
yeah like he can learn about his own
emotions absolutely and even
strengthening communication like what
your needs are like your needs clearly
in the situation where where she was
hurt by the senior um was to was to have
someone just to support her like she she
was hurt because of this event that
happened and she needed to get it out
and just needed someone to listen to her
and that need didn't get met instead she
was met with someone invalidating her
feelings yeah so she needs to
communicate that like she has these
needs that like
you know sometimes i just need to be
comforted after this thing happens i
want my partner to like hug me and
tell me that you know it's going to be
okay or whatever um sometimes guys need
to fix things yeah and if they can't fix
they just get angry at it yeah my dad
used to be like that where like i would
be crying about something and he
couldn't fix it so he'd just get mad at
me for it like he'd just get mad at me
for crying about it and it's his their
own not being able to work it out or
understand that you just need empathy
you don't yeah
a solution right now right to it um but
we have some really good sponsors that
you might well that might help your
situation happen yeah like for example
finding the perfect bra there's some
support that you need to support exactly
there you go and that's where third love
comes in third love creates high quality
underwear sleep and loungewear
delivering life-changing comfort your
body loves being in
and my body definitely loves being in
third love um actually though
because of this pregnancy i've kind of
outgrown my bra but it's still
supporting me really well i do need to
get new bras they have a quiz that helps
you find your exact perfect size which
is awesome yeah that's exactly it and so
you'll find the exactly perfect fit so
like for me for example
my
boobs were perfectly fit with their love
previous to pregnancy but then now that
they've gotten bigger and you've got
giant mommy milkers
yeah i need to like size up because yeah
they're definitely like spilling out
but
even though that even though they're
spilling on this is not a proper fit
anymore for my body there's it's still
really comfortable and it doesn't like
the straps don't dig into my shoulder
even the fact that like they're kind of
spilling out a bit the
cups aren't digging into my skin and the
band isn't digging in so it's not
creating that like back
uh that situation roll yeah so
i'm still so in love with third love and
i'm definitely gonna be purchasing a
bigger size now
you can get the level of fit and comfort
you deserve with their love bras
underwear and loungewear find your new
favorite everyday essentials from
loungewear to the number one rated 24 7
classic t-shirt bra which i'm actually
wearing right now but i'm not going to
show you
the simple quiz factors in size breast
shape current fit issues and your
personal style to find the perfect bras
and underwear for you no more awkward
dressing room moments take the fitting
room quiz from the comfort of your home
third love knows you deserve to feel
comfortable and confident 24 7. so right
now they're offering our listeners 20
off your first order go to thirdlove.com
big mood now to find your perfect
fitting bra and get 20 off your first
purchase that's thirdlove.com big mood
for 20 off today and if you want long
lush natural hair check out nutrifoal as
a hair growth supplement this is a brand
new sponsor to the show welcome them
they support healthy hair growth from
within by targeting the five root causes
of thinning which are stress hormones
environment nutrition and metabolism so
neutrophil is a physician formulated
product that is 100 percent drug free
they use medical grade botanicals in
consistently effective dosages so that
you get the most reliable results and
thousands of women have taken back
control of their hair with neutrophil
with many users raving that the
supplement not only transformed their
hair but restored their confidence too
hair is a really
big self-esteem factor right
now like once you start you know losing
it or thinning out it's not what you're
used to you start feeling like you're
losing part of you so i totally
understand this how that could restore
confidence neutral offers two targeted
formulas for women that are clinically
shown to improve hair growth and
thickness with less shedding throughout
all stages of life and you'll begin to
experience results in three to six
months you can grow thicker healthier
hair and support our show by going to
nutrafull.com and entering promo code
big mood to save 15
off your first month's subscription this
is their best offer anywhere okay and
it's only available to us customers for
a limited time plus free shipping on
every order that's 15 off at
nutrifold.com spelt
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l-dot-com
promo code big mood for big hair you
could go like hey
there you go all right the ute um so
this is the first one that we've read so
far that i'm not completely sold on
sending you back to the streets i think
that
communication is just a factor here that
yeah you guys could use and benefit from
yeah and it sounds like she has a little
bit of relationship anxiety where she's
been in this relationship and she's
unsure if she should stay or not i think
that could also be worked out yeah she's
also aware of that too yeah so i mean
the fact that you know that you suffer
from this and your first instinct is to
always to just leave that already tells
you that it might not be the
relationship because
the thing about relationship anxiety is
that it follows you to every
relationship you go to so
every relationship has problems all the
ones were in and
it doesn't sound like anything unhealthy
is going on here if you need more love
support and pampering when you're going
through tough times you can easily
communicate that and give him the
opportunity to be there for you
when you need those things yeah yeah
this one's not racing any red flags for
me let him know how to love you yeah and
have him do the same back and then you
guys can respect each other's
needs and boundaries
and it has to be he has to be responding
to it though yeah yeah i've been through
the same thing too where i was having a
breakdown and he got mad at me because
he didn't understand how to what i do is
me or what the [ __ ] you know just starts
like getting angry and then i realized
that i had to communicate and be like yo
i need you to hold me right now
and then later on we talked about he's
like thank you for teaching me because i
don't know these things because guys are
not taught to there's no manuals for
relationships and every girl is
different so yeah i need their space
some girls like to be like held some
girls don't even know what they want
yeah they have to learn too same thing
with oral sex
so if you talk about it and there is
actual action and effort then i think
you'll be okay but if you talked about
this over and over again and nothing's
happening then yeah maybe take a peek
out in the streets
peek out the window
all right the ute all right good luck to
you thank you
good luck to you to you
okay gina next one it's a female stacy's
huge rock
star this is a huge rock
all right you shiny
super shiny super beautiful i'm gonna
like you
i don't know how you're not constantly
like i know
in the sun just like look at it i look
at it all the time and i'm working on
the computer editing and i'm like oh
yeah yeah i love it
i took danny all the time i'm like i
love you so much
okay so they write hello i just wanted
to quickly say i love your podcast so
much and it has helped me in so many
ways
i'd like to stay anonymous please i've
been with my boyfriend for a little over
two years now and i'd say this is the
first serious relationship where i felt
it has been the most healthy slash
genuine yay
he always makes time for me he gets
along with my family and his love shows
wait what and his love shows his love
and his love
shows he loves the bachelors love shows
he loves it he shares a lot of island
huge fans
i have an excuse
i have a reason
all my blood is going to my uterus okay
all right so she says it's always a good
time when we're together but the only
thing that makes it difficult is his
anger oh no i realize that when we have
a disagreement he always says he doesn't
care and tells me to leave
it truly hurts me when i hear him say
these words so easily if any one of my
friends or sisters were in my situation
i'd definitely definitely tell them to
leave
i've always been transparent in letting
him know that i never wanted to waste
any of our times and if either of us
ever felt or fell out of love
we'd let the other know asap i'm not
sure if i'm just in my head because we
recently got into an argument or if i am
truly fed up thoughts
well you're definitely heated from just
being out of an argument so but that's
not mutually exclusive like you could
still be having these
feelings regardless um but he definitely
needs to go to therapy
well and also
i think anger issues don't excuse shitty
behavior exactly because
there's a certain set of rules in every
relationship everyone's different but
there are some there's certain things
you don't say regardless of how mad you
are for example in my relationship
breaking up you don't say that yes you
mean it um leaving you don't you don't
say that unless you mean it right um
bad words like directly like i have
never been called a [ __ ] i have never
been i have never called them out of his
name because those things are
like bombs to the relationship and every
time you do those it's it gets a little
bit closer to the end yep yep and a
relationship is not he's so great but a
relationship is he's great and
he's also really loving even when we're
upset we understand each other or we try
our best
i think uh for someone like me because i
learned through therapy i'm working on
myself thank you thank you
i'm poor now
i have i learned that i have abandonment
issues so if my significant other is
constantly saying get out it's just like
you're not
building a safe space for me you're not
my home you're not making me feel secure
um
so
he needs to work on that and i i from
what i've learned it's because people
like that never learned proper conflict
resolution yeah so they would rather get
rid of the problem yeah and it's their
trump card it's just like all right get
out you know and that is very uh
counterproductive
it's very damaging because the problem
here is your feelings and you can get
rid of those even if they remove you out
of the situation you still need to deal
with that exactly yeah yeah and then it
just makes the other person feel like
something you can just toss out yeah
like yeah just take me like they're not
allowed to have a bad day or a
disagreement with you or anything or
else they can be discarded yeah the
relationship is hanging by a thread
i know man that's that's some really
tough [ __ ] because this is similar
to what i've been through yeah and it
completely deteriorates the trust in the
relationship like you feel like you
build something and then next thing you
know like they'll throw some [ __ ] out
and it's like oh [ __ ] we're actually
back down to square one or negative one
again like we can't build because then
immediately it'll just get thrown out
the window exactly yeah it's really
disheartening and it's really hard to
build anything with that and especially
the anger issue part like one thousand
percent he needs to go to therapy or
else this is never gonna get fixed yeah
and i think it's a difference like the
the per the person earlier who said you
know
we
um what did she say that he kind of
dismisses her a little bit
that this sounds different like anger
issues and getting rid of her
is different than i don't know how to
help you with your problems if your
partner's like i don't know what to do
with your feelings rather than you need
to get out because i'm done dealing with
this yeah you know like the earlier
person i was like you know he could work
out with therapy this person anguishes
could also be worked out with therapy
the only thing is if you stay while he's
working on those he knows he can always
do those things to you and you'll stay
setting a precedent yeah so
the the difference is if you were to
break up with him and he works on that
and then he comes looking for you he
knows you won't tolerate that if you
stay with him through this process of
healing he knows he can always do this
to you and revert back to his old ways
and you'll continue to stay and that's
where that kind of gets tough that's so
true yeah it should feel like your
partner you guys are on the same team
attacking the disagreement or the issue
together and you both want a resolution
not like oh this is your issue because i
disagree with it so you need to go yeah
yeah
that's it's just not healthy at all and
you deserve somebody who wants to hear
you out and
somebody that's willing to sit through
the discomfort of an argument because
nobody likes to argue especially with
your partner yeah it's uncomfortable and
you just want to get over it so you can
go back to loving each other
but
you deserve to have somebody tell you
this is so uncomfortable and i don't
know how to work it out but i'm gonna
stay here yes or if we need a break
let's take a break but
i'll be here for you yeah because
otherwise he can be a great guy he could
treat you right like all this stuff like
he makes time for you all the good
things that you said but he's a fair
weather friend he's only there went for
the good times he's not there for if
anything goes bad and it goes
what do you do you just pretend things
are always good all the time yeah shiny
so you can keep him or yeah it goes the
other way too like you can't be the
person like
you can't also be like you know what i
don't want to deal with this i'm leaving
yeah you can't constantly just like
leave or tell someone to leave all the
time too there's no safety and security
there exactly i think a relationship
needs grit
right like a relationship built itself
on hard times but not harmful times yes
like never the expensive principles
yeah oh that should be my next question
it's really good yeah no but yeah
english version
oh my god
well it sounded really
[Laughter]
i always keep at the forward of my mind
danny's feelings well first my feelings
and then his it's never i want to be so
comfortable that i don't care what
happens to you
because then you love that person and
when somebody truly loves you they won't
do those things exactly they want to
protect you they want to help you they
you're
you're caring for each other well i feel
like if someone truly
loves you and is is mature and like is
is like able to like handle that because
i feel like there could be love but
you're just not maturely there yet to
even handle
those situations yeah and that's where
therapy comes in and you can really grow
and get to that point because like i
said like i relate to this [ __ ] so
like
now
with with so much therapy and so much
growth and and better communication like
i can tell you all along casey's loved
me but he just wasn't equipped with the
pro with the right tools to handle these
situations properly so he'll revert to
his immature ways which would be anger
or or uh dismissing me or whatever it
was and
that i just feel like comes from a place
of immaturity versus not loving me you
know yeah i agree the only thing the
difference here i would say and again
you're married this person's not so like
i said earlier if you're not married you
have an opportunity to go find somebody
who's healthy and not that these people
are not healthy but they do have a lot
of their work
yeah yeah and
when you make the decision to marry
someone it's for better for worse for
sickness and in health and when you're
not married you get the opportunity to
find the best
person that you're gonna have to do the
least amount of work with right so
here in this situation
if there's no kids if there's no
marriage i don't necessarily see the
point of grinding this out like i said
earlier you guys can go your separate
ways he can go to therapy and then if he
still wants to be with you and hold that
space for you
go ahead but grinding that out with
someone you know how hard it is yeah
because you went through it right and we
had a kid and we were practically
married without the legal because we
lived together ever since six months
yeah together so it was
we definitely were in a completely
different situation than this yeah so
that's the only difference like grinding
those years out like you have if you
have no kids and you're not married you
have no reason to
you know you it hurts but
i think the the lack of that's where
your self-love has to kick in and say i
love you but i love me more and i don't
deserve to be treated this way
so i the difference is like the
love has to come from within yourself to
say even though i love you and i want to
be with you i'll wait for you and if i'm
available then come look for me but i'm
not going to be disrespected this way
it's valuing yourself yeah yeah and
putting yourself through that that's
true yeah yeah for everybody that's
submitted i think that they you should
divine some herbs divine you should
divide decide on some clear
non-negotiables yeah write those down
because a lot of people don't
don't know where their boundaries are so
it's hard for them to to explain to
their partner
yeah and then you have to stick to your
boundaries yeah which is the hard part
but you got to do it reinforcing yes
that's the superheart
yeah you're letting people know how to
treat you yep
it was a i heard a quote recently i was
like if somebody ever disrespects you
ask them like
do you think that everyone treats me
this way do you do you think i allow
everyone to treat me this way or do you
think that or do you want me to just
make an exception for you
you know yeah and i was like oh [ __ ]
okay that yeah that really resonated
yeah yeah why are you special
yeah so thank you everyone for
subscribing yeah thank you i hope we
were able to give you some big rock the
you know
the writings
or something
eyes yeah what was it
everyone thank you so much for
submitting um you guys that are watching
make sure to submit your own oh yeah if
you want to submit to us follow us
on instagram at big move girls that's
where we collect submissions and also we
request all sorts of stuff so excuse you
i'm busy
just one of you right now i know
messaging and um just hold off to the
next episode also check out stacey on
instagram on youtube she got apodaca
jewels all kinds of stuff she just got
engaged go watch your videos on that and
uh subscribe and make sure that our
sponsors sponsors that's that's the best
way you can show your support for this
buy something
please
bye make sure you check out the
description there's all the links all
the codes
and
five stars thumbs up thumbs up we love
you
that's cute